In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 23rd, on which we commemorate the Holy New
Martyr Nikolas the Grocer slain by the sword at Constantinople in the year 1672.
Saint Nikolas was the son of a Grocer in Constantinople.
During what a keen and able student he was, his devout parents did all they could to give
him a good education.
When he was 15, his father brought him in to help with the business, and at the same time
arranged for him to have lessons in Turkish from the neighboring barber.
The youth made astonishing progress and showed uncommon intelligence so his teacher with
the cooperation of the devil looked about for a means of getting him to become a Muslim.
One day, at the end of a lesson, when there were some janissaries in the shop, he handed him
the Muslim confession of faith as if it were a reading exercise.
The young man obediently read it without knowing what it was about, and the Turks shouted
for joy when he had finished, wanting thereby to make Nikolas aware of what he had done.
But he would have none of it, and proclaimed his fidelity to Christ before them all.
He was brought before the judge who tried in his turn to persuade him by flattery's and
enticing propositions.
He then spent 65 days imprisoned with criminals, and deprived of bread and water.
When he was brought out, his face was radiant with joy, and with a light not of this world.
Neither blows nor threats of torture and death could weaken his resolve, and so he was condemned
to death on the pretext of having repudiated the Muslim faith.
Nikolas made his way to the place of execution as radiant as if he were going to his bridal chamber.
After his innocent head fell beneath the executioner's sword, everyone could see a divine light
surrounding his body during the three following nights.
His holy relics worked many miracles of healing for those who drew near them with faith.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.